chris johnson lo que busca es ganar el
mejor acuerdo posible para los intereses
del reino unido- este protocolo sobre
irlanda del norte que hace parte de la
ley del mercado interno es un as bajo la
manga del primer ministro para presionar
en las negociaciones y buscar lo mejor
para ello especialmente en derechos
pesqueros sin embargo todavía hay
posibilidades de que se pueda retirar
esta cláusula siempre y cuando se llegue
a un acuerdo del brics y de la futura
negociación de la futuro como será esa
relación futura a partir del primero de
enero de 2021 todo como les digo
pendientes entonces de esto que sucede
en esta cláusula recordemos irlanda la
isla irlanda está dividida en dos la
república hace parte de la unión europea
y el norte de irlanda está en el reino
unido una vez el reino unido- sale de la
unión europea este esta línea que en la
que no hay una frontera física se
convierte prácticamente en una aduana y
en una frontera por ello la importancia
de proteger el acuerdo del viernes santo
lo que se espera entonces es que el
primer ministro
lo que ha dicho además es que tendría
que si se impone lo que la unión europea
quiere entonces el reino del río se
partiría la unión europea lo que
pretende es proteger el acuerdo de paz
entonces luisa si estos artículos en
cuestión violan lo que había sido
acordado por bruselas y londres sobre la
situación entre irlanda e irlanda del
norte como podría responder la unión
europea
por supuesto la unión europea' ha
despertado y ha dicho que esto sería ir
en contra de la ley internacional en el
reino unido- también hay división el
propio partido del primer ministro está
dividido porque esto sería ir en contra
de la buena fe ya se firmó el acuerdo
entonces lo que pretende boris johnson
para ganar un mejor break sheet futuro
entonces sería romper esta ley
internacional los países europeos están
por supuesto furiosos por lo que va a
suceder pero no es una realidad
únicamente que seguir en europa aquí
internamente también dado que el reino
unido- dice que tiene gran credibilidad
a nivel internacional así que esta
presunción de boris johnson está bien
compleja pero lo que les digo hay que
estar pendientes de cómo avanzan las
negociaciones en bruselas si finalmente
hay acuerdo esta noche entonces esos
parágrafos se retirarían de la ley del
mercado interno